what we're going to do in this video is
get some practice taking derivatives
with the power rule so let's say we need
to take the derivative with respect to x
of
1 over x what is that going to be equal
to pause this video and try to figure it
out
so at first you might say how does the
power rule apply here the power rule
just to remind ourselves it tells us
that if we're taking the derivative of x
to the n with respect to x so if we're
taking the derivative of that that
that's going to be equal to we take the
exponent bring it out front and we've
proven it in other videos but this is
going to be n times x to the and then we
decrement the exponent so n
minus 1. but this does not look like
that and the key is to appreciate that 1
over x is the same thing as x to the
negative 1. so this is going to be the
derivative with respect to x of
x to the negative 1. and now this looks
a lot more like what you might be used
to where this is going to be equal to
you take our exponent bring it out front
so that's negative 1 times x to the
negative 1 minus 1 negative 1 minus 1.
and so this is going to be equal to
negative x to the
negative 2 and we're done
let's do another example
let's say that we're told that f of x is
equal to the cube root of x and we want
to figure out what f prime of x is equal
to pause the video and see if you can
figure it out again
well once again you might say hey how do
i take the derivative of something like
this especially if my goal or if i'm
thinking that maybe the power rule might
be useful
and the idea is to rewrite this as an
exponent if you could rewrite the cube
root as
x to the one-third power
and so the derivative you take the
one-third bring it out front so it's
third
x to the
one third minus one power and so this is
going to be one third times x to the one
third minus one is negative two thirds
negative two thirds power and we are
done and hopefully through these
examples you're seeing that the power
rule is incredibly powerful you can you
can tackle a far broader range of
derivatives than you might have
initially thought let's do another
example and i'll make this one really
nice and hairy let's say we want to
figure out the derivative with respect
to x
of
the cube root of
x squared
what is this going to be and actually
let's just not figure out what the
derivative is let's figure out the
derivative at
x equals 8.
pause this video again and see if you
can figure that out
well what we're going to do is first
just figure out what this is and then
we're going to evaluate it at x equals
8.
and the key thing to appreciate is this
is the same thing and we're just going
to do what we did up here as the
derivative with respect to x instead of
saying the cube root of x squared we
could say this is x squared
to the one-third power which is the same
thing as the derivative with respect to
x
of
well x squared if i raise something to
an exponent and then raise that to an
exponent i could just take the product
of the exponents and so this is going to
be x to the 2 times 1 3 power or to the
two thirds power
and now this is just going to be equal
to i'll do it right over here bring the
two thirds out front two-thirds times x
to the what's two-thirds minus one
well that's 2 3 minus 3 3 or it would be
negative 1 3 power and we want to know
what happens at x equals 8 so let's just
evaluate that that's going to be 2 3
times x is equal to 8 to the negative 1
3 power
well what's 8 to the 1 3 power 8 to the
1 3 power is going to be equal to 2
and so 8 to the negative 1 3 power is
one half actually let me just do that
step by step
so this is going to be equal to two
thirds times we could do it this way one
over eight to the one third power
and so this is just one over two
two-thirds times one-half
well d that's just going to be equal to
one-third and we're done